يقول منتقدوك إن هذا يظهر أن هذه الحرب
فاشلة، وأود أن أزعم أن هذا كله
غير صحيح يا ميدي، فنحن نضرب كاماس بشدة وهم
يشعرون بالألم الذي
ناقشناه للتو منذ لحظة، لماذا ربما
يفكرون الآن بجدية في
إطلاق سراح الرهائن، فهذا ليس بسبب  كما
قلت، لقد أصبحوا عاملين في المجال الإنساني، وذلك
لأنهم يتعرضون
لضغوط عسكرية هائلة جدًا. هذه
العملية ليست تلك التي أردناها. من
الواضح أن هذه الحرب فرضت على
إسرائيل في الهجوم الرهيب الذي وقع في
7 أكتوبر ونحن نقاوم  وسوف
ندمر منا، سنقوم بتفكيك
آلتهم العسكرية وسنفكك
سيطرتهم السياسية على غزة،
وهذا أمر جيد لإسرائيل لأسباب واضحة،
لا يتعين علينا أن نعيش في خوف من
الإرهابيين الذين يعبرون الحدود
ويقتلون شعبنا و  ذبح
أطفالنا في منتصف الليل ولكنه
في النهاية أمر جيد أيضًا وآمل أن
تتفق معي أنه سيكون جيدًا
لشعب غزة الذي يستحق أفضل من
نظام حماس الاستبدادي المتطرف الرهيب الذي لا يزال سكان غزة على
قيد الحياة مثلي.  قل أكثر من 11000
قتيل تم الإبلاغ عن مقتل 4000 طفل
أريد فقط أن أسحب أرقام حماس حماس
تقول حماس تقول
أرقام حماس التي يجب أن أشير إليها فقط اسحب
على الشاشة في آخر صراعين كبيرين في غزة
عامي 2009 و 2014
الجيش الإسرائيلي  لقد تطابق عدد الوفيات مع
عدد القتلى في وزارة الصحة التابعة لحماس، لذا فإن
مجموعات حقوق الإنسان التابعة للأمم المتحدة تتفق جميعها على أن هذه
الأرقام ذات مصداقية ولكن انظر إلى
وجهة نظرك الأوسع صحيحة، هل يمكنني أن
أتحدى ذلك، هل تسمح لي بتحدي ذلك من فضلك، هل
يمكنني فقط تحدي ذلك لتحدي
هؤلاء  يتم توفير الأرقام من قبل حماس،
ولا يوجد تحقق مستقل،
وثانيًا، والأهم من ذلك، ليس لديك أي
فكرة عن عدد
المقاتلين الإرهابيين التابعين لحماس وعدد
المدنيين الذين تريد حماس أن تصدقهم
أن جميع المدنيين جميعهم
أطفال، وهنا يجب أن نقول
شيء لا يقال بما فيه الكفاية حماس
حتى الآن تدمر
آلتهم العسكرية وبهذا نقوم بتآكل
سيطرتهم ولكن حتى الآن
كانوا يسيطرون على قطاع غزة
ونتيجة لذلك يسيطرون على جميع الصور التي
تخرج من  غزة، هل رأيتم
صورة واحدة لإرهابي واحد من حماس ميت
أثناء القتال في غزة، لا يمكن لأحد أن
يتحكم في
المعلومات، لكني رأيت
الكثير من الأطفال بعيني الكاذبة
يتم سحبهم من تحت الأنقاض لأنهم
الصور التي تريد حماس منك أن تلتقطها.  انظر
انظر
بالضبط الصور هناك أيضًا أشخاص
قتلتهم حكومتك، هل تقبل هذا
الحق، لقد قتلت أطفالًا أم أنك
تنكر ذلك لا، لا أفعل، لا أفعل،
أولاً وقبل كل شيء، أنت لا تعرف كيف
مات هؤلاء الأشخاص هؤلاء الأطفال أولاً  من بين كل شيء،
نحن لا نريد أن نرى طفلاً واحداً
يُقتل، ولكن لماذا يجب أن نصدق ما
تقوله حكومتك. كما أن
المتحدث باسمك العسكري يوم الاثنين أشار إلى
وثيقة باللغة العربية في قبو أحد
مستشفيات غزة وادعى أنها
قائمة أوصياء مسجلة فيها كل طفل.  إرهابي
يكتب اسمه ولكن هذا كان خطأ،
كان مجرد تقويم أنا لا أتفق معه وأعتقد أنه فيما يتعلق
بقضايا الاستيراد، انظر
سأعطيك مثالاً، لقد
قدرنا في الأصل الإجابة على سؤالك، اسمح
لي بالإجابة على سؤالك، فأنا أجيب على
سؤالك مباشرة  إذا سمحتم
لي أه قلنا في الأصل في
هجوم حماس الفظيع على شعبنا يوم
7 أكتوبر كان العدد 1400
ضحية والآن قمنا بتخفيض ذلك
إلى 1200 لأننا فهمنا
أننا بالغنا في تقديرنا لقد
أخطأنا  لقد كانت في الواقع جثثًا
احترقت بشدة واعتقدنا أنها
جثثنا في النهاية، ويبدو أنهم كانوا
إرهابيين من كاماس لماذا يمنحك ذلك
الإذن لماذا يمنحك ذلك
الإذن بقبول أرقام حماس؟
لا أفهم لم أسأل عن
حماس  أرقام قلت لك إن
جيشك كنت تنقله لي قبل
اجتماع أرقام حماس، كنت تنقل
لي أرقام حماس لأن الأمم المتحدة بأكملها
ومجتمع حقوق الإنسان
ومجتمع الاستخبارات الأمريكي
قالوا يوم الجمعة إنهم يثقون في هذه الأرقام ولكنك
يتهرب من علامة الاستفهام الخاصة بي،
لماذا يشير المتحدث باسمك العسكري يوم
الاثنين إلى تقويم باللغة العربية
ويقول إن هذه هي أسماء الإرهابيين الموجودة عليها، وهذا
خطأ، هل يمكنك القبول هنا
والآن أنا أنا أنا أنا لست على علم بما
في الصورة التي لدينا الصورة  لقد
ارتكبت، لقد ارتكبت أخطاء، لقد ارتكبت
أخطاء، لكن هناك فرق
بين ارتكاب خطأ صادق وبين
حماس التي تتعمد
تضخيم الأرقام بما يتناسب مع
أغراضها الدعائية، هناك
أصوات ضخمة، لذا انتظرك وقلت دعاية، هل
يمكننا التعامل مع زميلك فحسب؟
تغريدة أوفيا غيلمان لا تزال قائمة
بعد مرور سبعة أيام، لماذا لم يتم عرضها، إنه
فيلم لبناني قصير يمكننا عرضه على
الشاشة، ليس الفلسطينيين الذين يزيفون
إصاباتهم، هل يمكننا أن نعترف بهذا
الخطأ ونحذفه، فهذه
ليست
دعاية مرة واحدة  مرة أخرى أفهم أن
هذا كان خطأً أيضًا، وإذا
أردت سأتحدث
إلى عفراء حول هذا الموضوع إذا أردت فهو
صديق لي وزميل أنا
أحبه تمامًا إنه رجل طيب أماي إيلاهو الذي
قال إن على إسرائيل أن تفكر في ذلك  إسقاط
قنبلة نووية على غزة من شأنها أن تقتل
أكثر من مليوني شخص، فهو لا يزال في
حكومتك، مارك، هل تفهم
لماذا لا يمكن سماع ذلك على أنه أي شيء
آخر غير دعوات للإبادة الجماعية أو
التطهير العرقي في جميع أنحاء العالم التي
وبخها رئيس الوزراء
إلياهو و  قيل له بصراحة شديدة
أنه تم إيقافه عن العمل في الحكومة،
وإذا أدلى بأي تصريحات كهذه
مرة أخرى فسيتم طرده من عايدة، وأعتقد أنني
أتفق بالفعل مع ما قاله، إن
المأساة التي حلت
بالفلسطينيين في 1947-1948 كانت
بسبب  قيادة متطرفة غير مسؤولة
لم تكن على استعداد لتقديم تنازلات،
وحماس تفعل نفس الشيء
للفلسطينيين في غزة، فظيع أعرف
لا تخبرني، أنا لا أعرف
تاريخي اليهودي، أعرف تاريخي اليهودي، اذهب
وهاجم الأماليس، لا تفعل ذلك.  تجنب
قتل الرجال والنساء والأطفال، وهذا ما
تفعله في غزة، وهذا ما
كان يصفه رئيس الوزراء، لا، لا،
لا أحد في إسرائيل
يدعو إلى قتل النساء والأطفال
على العكس من ذلك، كيف يمكنك أن تفعل ذلك؟  ماذا
قال وزير تراثكم في
غزة لا لا لا لا لا، ما قلناه هو
أننا سنقضي على حماس
وسنقضي على حمص، هل تدعم
حكومتك رئيس الوزراء نانيو
حل الدولتين، نعم  أو لا،
أعتقد أن هذا هو وقت الحرب الآن، إنه
وقت النصر وعندما ينتهي ذلك
مع هزيمة حماس وتدمير حماس،
عندما تقضي على
العدو الأكثر تطرفًا للسلام، فإن ذلك يفسح المجال
أعتقد لأصوات أكثر اعتدالًا وواقعية
لملء الفراغ وهذا سيكون
مفيدًا للسلام، نعم أو لا بشأن
حل الدولتين، لقد أعطيتك إجابة جيدة كما
اعتقد السفير
مارك